los migrantes también celebran el mes
del orgullo en la frontera Sur mexicana
decenas de migrantes pertenecientes a la
población
lgbtiq más salieron a las calles de
Tapachula para promover la inclusión y
el respeto a sus identidades de género y
orientaciones sexuales a través del arte
por las personas que han sido
discriminadas y ofendidas incluyendo
aquellas personas que también han pasado
durante un proceso migratorio migrando
por ser personas de la diversidad sexual
muchos son perseguidos en sus países de
origen por su condición y se fueron En
búsqueda de Refugio que busca sobre todo
promover espacios incluyentes en la
ciudad donde todas todos y todas nos
sintamos seguros y sobre todo incluidos
pero lejos del color y la celebración
cientos de migrantes siguen varados en
la zona sus hogares son campamentos
improvisados fuera de los albergues que
no pueden recibir a todos debido a su
saturación ande los han dado permiso es
para para solo cocinar ahí adentro para
allá para estabilizarlo estabilizar una
una carpa dentro no podemos poner ahí
porque nos dan permiso para cocinar y
lavar la ropa ahí adentro son casi dos
meses desde el fin del título 42 en los
Estados Unidos y aunque no se han
registrado aumentos en los cruces
fronterizos al norte de México la
frontera Sur sigue funcionando como un
embudo que dificulta el tránsito al
sueño americano